what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the venom run which you
guys really really seem to enjoy and
indeed the venom runs really really good
but here's the funny thing in this one
apparently we're starting a new story
arc i didn't realize the first one was
only two issues which is kind of cool uh
but basically we're switching over to in
a lot of ways the story of dylan right
so we don't really see much of eddie
brock in this instead what we do is we
switch over to the headquarters of the
reformed life foundation now for those
of you guys who don't know who the life
foundation is or need a bit of a
refresher because we've talked about
them before uh the life foundation in
all honesty their purpose kind of seems
it seems to be evolving right because
when they originally appeared back at
lethal protector the nature of the life
foundation is that they were kind of an
aftermath to the cold war and basically
this idea was that humanity would
ultimately destroy itself and indeed
that was the actual concern right i
never personally lived through the cold
war i mean i guess i did i was born in
1984 but i wasn't old enough to
understand what was going on um but but
anybody who lived through the cold war
talking to my my grandparents and you
know so on and so forth that the biggest
fear was that a an actual nuclear war
would take place between the united
states and the soviet union that's why
the cold war is referred to as the cold
war because the united states and russia
didn't actually go to war with each
other it was the soviet union backing
governments and basically trying to
implement communism in different
countries while the united states was
trying to implement capitalism in
different countries so it was as much an
economic war as it was a war between
various nations each one fighting on
behalf of either the soviet union or the
united states but the nature of the life
foundation is they believe that because
of the cold war somewhere along the line
something would happen and either the
united states or the soviet union would
press the button missiles would go
flying and that would be the end of
everything and so what they did is they
built this giant bunker but in order to
make sure that once everything evolved
like once everything kind of settled
down and that the well really it's an
antiquated concept but the idea of
nuclear winter basically came to an end
that they could ascend to the surface
and basically rule the world but in
order to ensure that the world was ruled
under their their guidance right there
weren't really any kind of uh competing
forces out there they basically created
different symbiotes based off the venom
symbiote and that's where you got like
phage and scream and different
characters like that from back in the
day and so the funny thing is that where
carlton drake the old man here was the
guy who led the group originally while
they were based in the cold war
obviously as we know the cold war didn't
end the way that you expected it to and
so in a lot of ways the question to ask
here is what purpose does the life
foundation serve anymore and it's
probably just the idea that like meow
because of the the development of the
nuclear age and because of the fact that
nuclear weapons still exist and humanity
just can't get itself together at some
point on the line something will happen
things will pop off and this fear that
was rooted in the cold war of the world
ending through some kind of armed
conflict that it's still there right it
still rains but one of the cool things
about this is that carlton drake was
always very intrigued by the symbiotes
even if his intrigue led him to viewing
them as a kind of protectionary force or
a weapon that could be used for the life
foundation's own ends when he's talking
to carson basically this guy who led uh
the forces to initially face off against
venom well they're all talking and and
carlton drake is basically running over
a lot of what we know right that the
symbiotes originated from space
somewhere and then we found out they
originated from nol and basically all
the information that we've gained over
the years from the time that venom first
appeared in marvel comics running all
the way up to the life foundation and a
lot of the stories that have taken place
since then that what he says is for all
the things we've learned we still don't
really know anything the only thing we
know is that every time we try to defeat
a symbiote using sonics or fire or what
have you they find some way to evolve
whether it's because they bond
themselves to spider-man or they bond
themselves to someone like eddie brock
or whatever the case is that they're
evolved from a god at the end of the day
humanity just doesn't really seem to
have the ability to overcome them and
that's when he kind of chimes in and
says the biggest issue that held the
life foundation back in understanding
the nature of the symbiotes that
humanity defines things by its function
and when carson asks like what do you
you know i don't understand like what
are you talking about he uses the
example of an umbrella and he's like
what's the purpose of an umbrella and
the response of carson is to say well to
keep the rain from getting on you and
the answer of carlton drake is yes but
say that we punched a hole in it and
rain came through the umbrella at that
point does it cease to be an umbrella
does it stop being one or is it simply
just an umbrella with holes in it but if
we define an umbrella by its function
which is to keep the rain from getting
on us but it's no longer able to do that
then what is it now and that's what's so
interesting is because he sees the
symbiotes as kind of this reflection of
evolution and that was always the way
the life foundation saw symbiotes as
kind of this evolutionary imperative not
in so far as it was the next stage of
humanity but insofar as they could use
the technology of the symbiotes or the
nature of the symbiotes to improve
humanity as a whole and so that's when
he's kind of like what the one thing
that we need here more than anything
else we need to poke holes in these
simians right we need to figure the
limits of their ability to adapt the
limits of their ability to evolve at
what point can we reach some level of
weaponry to where when we face off
against the symbiote there's nothing it
can do to stop us right there's nothing
it can do to overcome us that we can
completely and totally overwhelm these
things and so at that point you actually
switch over to the the venom symbiote
itself now remember the venom symbiote
is absent of dylan at the moment and
it's kind of out there doing its own
thing sort of hanging around i mean it
hasn't really abandoned dylan but it
sort of discusses its own existence and
to a degree even laments its own
existence right it's simply saying that
over the course of the time since it was
created until the modern day it served a
lot of different purposes during the
pre-scroll war it was modded to tell
carc and it was really this this kind of
embodiment of like death and destruction
right everywhere the venom symbiote went
death was sure to follow and people
actually became fearful of it it was
created by null different things along
those lines and the time that eddie and
the venom symbiotes spent together when
they first appeared in marvel comics
that they were this just kind of
overwhelming force that not even
spider-man could stand against right
that it sees itself as this being that
hails from this this life and this this
kind of history of violence and
destruction right it was a thing to be
feared and now it looks at its existence
and it's like i'm a dog right like i'm a
companion that follows dylan and it's
not really meant to be humorous even
though it is to a degree it's one of
these things where the venom symbiote
sees itself as having fallen from grace
so incredibly far and the way that it
relates to this is it talks about this
idea that it's considered leaving dylan
right like abandoning dylan entirely and
going off and doing its own thing
presumably even if it has a possibility
cutting itself off from the hive mind of
eddie brock so not even eddie brock will
be able to detect this thing assuming
eddie's even still alive because if you
guys recall in the last video it looked
like eddie brock was dead and so because
of this the thing that always brings the
symbiote back is it seems to have these
memories of its time with eddie and
because of the emotional involvement
with the two of them it seems to have a
kind of loyalty to dylan right if only
for the life that the the venom symbiote
and eddie spent together that it's
almost like it owes it to dylan in order
to make sure that dylan stays safe now
at that point we switch over to archer
lyle and dylan himself now archer lyle
again is a very new character she
appeared in the last issue of venom
right so she's a brand new introduction
here but she's also what you would call
like an investigative reporter to a
degree in the sense that when she's
talking to dylan she talks about her
involvement with eddie brock and saying
that like you know the two of them
worked together when eddie was like a
young reporter trying to make his bones
right and trying to get himself out
there trying to get that big scoop right
that pulitzer prize-winning scoop so we
could make a name for himself among all
these different journalists out there
what he was initially going on for was
something called the lost gold scandal
but as time went on and he began to make
a name for himself he basically
disappeared right from archer lyle's
life just there she never really heard
from him for years until suddenly he
popped up and he said i am basically
gonna die here in a little while and the
group behind my death is basically the
absent throne now here's the cool thing
about this this is what i love about the
idea of the absent throne this reminds
me of project wide awake in so many ways
and those of you guys who are old enough
to remember the old x-men comics right
who have read through like chris
claremont's run or anything like that
the way the absent throne is pitched
here is that there's some kind of
clandestine shady organization that has
financial ties and political involvement
with everyone right so they're backing
like the friends of humanity they were
backing the life foundation all that
stuff and that when you follow the money
which is always what you do whenever
you're trying to track down some crony
corporation you always follow the trail
of money that it would lead to like
shell companies on top of shell
companies on top of shell companies a
great amount of effort was taken to keep
themselves hidden away from the world
and the reason why this reminds me of
project wide awake is that's how project
wide awake operate right i mean like you
go when you read the old chris claremont
x-men comics project wide awake as we've
talked about before was a
government-based organization but
everyone was involved in this right like
they had ties to corporations right they
had ties to like local police officers
right state sheriff's office the fbi the
assistant to the national security
adviser the president's personal
assistant like everybody was involved in
this right this just massive anti-mutant
crackdown to contain and control the
mutant threat so it's always really
interesting to see how things like like
chris claremont's x-men and like project
wide awake and even a lot of the the
shady organizations that came before
project wide awake still kind of repeat
themselves but in different capacities
but through her investigations and her
poking around archer lyle ended up
finding what appeared to be a small
research facility out in plymouth and so
her stance is like we're going to go
there or at least i'm going to go there
i'm going to investigate right hack
their computers whatever i need to do
get as much information as i can to add
to this existing information to see if i
can't figure out what's going on with
the absent throne now initially dylan
tries to tag along and where her
response is i mean no like i don't want
you there he's pretty adamant about it
right dylan kind of trying to prove
himself and show what he's capable of
and so the response of archer is okay
fine you can come along but you cannot
bring the venom symbiote because you've
demonstrated that whenever you get angry
you kind of quote unquote poke out when
it comes to the symbiote you can't quite
control yourself and that's always been
the biggest issue of dylan right
whenever dylan had the venom simian he
would always sort of lose control
because he's young because he's
impulsive and highly emotional he's just
at that age where like hormones govern
his life that his ability to control the
symbiote and to be methodical doesn't
really seem to exist and so if you were
to bring this symbiote with him it would
basically lead to a most likely
situation where his emotions would get
the better of him and the simi would
just go plowing through the entire
facility and if this whole thing is
supposed to be a super secret
investigation like espionage you don't
go in guns blazing right like you sneak
in so you can't really trust the
symbiote or even dylan with the cement
in that capacity but the response of
dylan is well i'm not going unarmed
right so he ultimately ends up bringing
sleeper this symbiote that's more of
like a spice i mean he ends up bringing
that with him and then of course the
main venom symbiote ends up staying
behind now as they get to exodynamics
which is this material research facility
the one they've been investigating in
plymouth of course archer's able to get
in there but with the help of uh of
sleeper dylan gets in there more
effectively than she does right so
obviously proving himself but once they
get into this this room with all these
computer systems right all these systems
they can hack they can gain information
from and so on dylan's led into a room
and the door shuts behind him and that's
when you find out the whole thing was a
trap that somewhere along the line in
her investigations the absent throne
found out lyle was looking into them and
as you would expect with any kind of
shady organization like this no risks
are taken right there's no real risk
taken here and so what they end up doing
is basically brokering a deal and saying
never look into us again or next time
we'll just kill you but like we will let
you go but give us dylan in your place
and she did right she basically set him
up like she set up dylan and so once
these forces of what's essentially
alkamax come pouring in here that
basically they incapacitate dylan with
tranquilizer darts and then they
incapacitate sleeper using sonics and
with these two taken out then you get
into the introduction of liz allen and
this is pretty rough right because
remember liz allen is tied in with like
harry osborne you going to read the
spider-man comics she seems like what
you know a little bit shady but like one
of the nicer people out there and this
she's cold-hearted and that's the nature
of liz allen right as the leader of
alcomax she's got two different faces
well she's got more than two faces but
you see largely two different sides of
it right you see the cold methodical
like whether dylan knows it or not right
he's right in the middle of what's
basically a symbiote arms race but then
you see like the spider-man version of
her where she's a little kinder and a
little gentler and kids and different
things like that right so putting on
those two different fronts but this
first and foremost is what's really
going on here and it was the expected
outcome null shows up on earth and like
attacks humanity almost conquers the
world and where most people out there
are just fleeing for their lives and
superheroes are trying to save the
general public and trying to stop this
threat people who are weapons
manufacturers major corporations they're
looking at this whole thing unfolding
and they're asking the question how can
we find a way to make money off this
that it really is a symbiote arms race
tony stark was not the only person to
think of bonding simian technology with
his own technology not the only person
to think of that and he wasn't the last
right alkamax was thinking of it the
life foundation was thinking of it and
presumably the friends of humanity were
working on something like that right
because they're not just a bunch of
ragtag crazy guys who are just ranting
in the streets about hating mutants the
friends of humanity is highly organized
they've come a long way since the days
of grey and creed right the friends of
humanity are a wholly different beast
now and so ultimately when you switch
back over to carlton drake and carson
the response of carson is okay like i
get what you're saying and this is
really really fascinating here's my
question how do you suggest we poke
holes in a symbiote well how do you
suggest we hunt down these symbiotes we
attack these symbiotes we find some way
to overcome them right because they seem
pretty capable to me and what you end up
finding out here is that the life
foundation has actually been working on
a powered suit that will serve the
purpose of essentially allowing them to
overcome symbiotes more so than that
looking at the nature of this suit it
looks like it's not just designed to be
earth-based it looks like it could
actually work in the vacuum of space but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end i'm really
intrigued to see what direction this
goes in i'm really looking forward to it
but anyway guys thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace